Hi. My name's Andy. And I work at Udacity and your instructor, Yoren. Well, he
lives in Germany. And so he couldn't be here today, but we're really lucky to
have Leonard Suskind here with us today.
And Leonard Suskind is a theoretical physicist at
Stanford. Can you just give a little bit
of, of information about your background. Well, [LAUGH]
I'm a human being. I come from earth. I
I came from New York City. I am a
Theoretical Physicist by profession. I think about things like black
holes and quantum field theory and elementary particles. In
cosmology and I spend most of my day doing that.
>> A differential equation?
>> Every single field of physics used differential
equations. There is nothing that doesn't differential equations.
so, yes I think a lot about differential equations. I, I, I don't
solve them very often. They are kind of hard to solve. And the,
I don't do a lot of numerics with it, but the mathematical structure
of differential equations is terribly important
to every branch of physics, every branch.
>> what do you mean when you say mathematical structure?
>> Well, there are different kind
of deferiential equations. They behave differently.
There are wavy equations that describe waves
moving along. There are diffusion equations. A diffusion
equation describes how a, a drop of ink that falls into some water. Okay, how
does the drop of ink diffuse throughout
the water? It doesn't make waves. It just,
grows and becomes a blob. Those are two
[NOISE] very, very different kinds of differential equations.
There are differential equations. That describe electrostatic
fields for example. Then electrostatic fields don't change
with time, so those are differential equations
that don't have to do with time, they
just tell you how things vary in
space. All these various differential equations, these different
kinds of differential equations have different kinds
of mathematical structure. If an experienced person looks
at an equation, a differential equation.
In a partial differential equation, usually you
can tell very quickly is that describing waves or does, does it describe
diffusion, or is it describing the electrostatic behavior of something? And you
get a pretty good feel by looking at the equation by its mathematical structure.
What kind of phenomena is describing. So, yeah, different equations
have different kind of structure and the structure is mathematical.